[inaudible]
in 1997 a psychologists conducted an
experiment that could lead any two people
to fall in love using just 36 questions.
We took those 36 questions and ask
them to three complete strangers
just to see what happens.
Tell refreshing.
All right.
When did you last sing to yourself?
I sing all the time, so I
see you too. My girlfriend,
my homie in Georgia,
the first school hang
man, she just go nuts.
Romantic. I wish I had that
talent. The thing to my girlfriend,
she called me on the phone. They love
it. Whatever you do, they love it.
That's great.
All right.
What is the greatest
accomplishment of your life?
I would say the greatest accomplishment
of my life is being able to reach my
dream of being a pro wrestler
around eight years old. Um,
you know, I discovered
professional wrestling and I
was glued to the television.
Um, my father was abusive, you
know, I didn't have a father figure,
so the people that I watched on TV were
like my heroes and right then I knew
that one day I wanted to be a
professional wrestler. That was my dream.
I developed a fan base of a
lot of children that don't
have like a father figure.
Being able to do that for kids.
Um, it's really important to me.
Okay.
Two doors and we see it without them.
There would be no change in me.
I was just wild and crazy
when I was young. Um,
and so I was a bad kid,
honestly afraid of nothing.
Talk to security. I'm like eight,
nine, just like what is wrong with you?
And so that's a lack of love.
And so not having a father and a
mom to really love you. But yeah,
just my daughters,
when they came to soften me,
I was combing their hair
and picking out clothes,
wearing dresses and for
them to make them smile.
And that was the greatest accomplishment
of all the things that I've done.
I respect you for that man.
Yes,
I would say for myself is
the greatest accomplishment.
It would definitely be as a trainer,
like being with actually change
someone's life in a positive way.
Growing up I was like
very skinny kid and um,
I was bullied a lot.
And so I was pretty,
I was an angry person and so I just
started training my room and it became
something that I realized was much
more positive than breaking things.
It's amazing, man. Thank
you. That's amazing.
You guys are very genuine.
I'm really, I really do it
Myra you for that. Thank you very
much. You're welcome. Thank you.
What is your most terrible memory?
Oh,
I can go first.
I was playing tennis.
I hit a ball and it hit on the bullies.
Um,
I remember him jumping
behind me and strangling me.
There were people around me and, uh,
instead of like standing out for me,
everyone was just laughing,
uh,
ridiculing me while it was like being
strangled and choked on the ground.
It was just a time where I really was
just going through a lot of mental
battles.
That was the time where I
would contemplate oftentimes
like suicidal thoughts at
times.
And so I would say that is like probably
one of the more terrible memories from
alive.
Yeah.
Um, one of my most terrible
memories is when I was 16,
I was shoplifting because all the kids
at school are wearing like all the fancy
clothes, like Nautica and Tommy
Hilfiger. And I wanted to be cool,
but we didn't have money so I would
steal clothes and I got caught.
I was only 16 years old.
I didn't know what to expect and
I was like crying and everything.
The security guard called my grandparents
and they were really disappointed in
me. And then they put me in
juvenile hall for a month.
That was the scariest
experience of my life.
I realized that I need to change my life.
So I stopped stealing,
never stole again.
So I think we have our terrible memories
for a reason to teach us and it allows
us to grow stronger. They're just
hurdles that we have to jump over.
Mine is been sick for like 12 years and
I was just depressed seeing everyone
smile and happy.
And here I am taking four or five
naps a day trying to survive,
losing jobs. And, uh, you never
say, why do you need, and you'd say,
why do you need what
you're actually saying?
Why not her or him give that to her?
And that's not fair.
So why not you?
What roles do love and affection,
play?
Love.
That word could change someone's life.
I just learned to say I love you.
And that was recently I told my nephew
that I love and he cried because his
father,
they did some studies who they spoke to,
snow floods
and one that is current
stack the snowflake.
It's just terrible looking and wanted.
They spoke love to.
It's just so beautiful
and it never changed.
So that's what happens when you speak
life into people and will you help them
raise your vibrations in your energy?
I love that sense.
Totally agree with that.
Life is all about love.
It's okay for a man to have
affection and show affection.
It doesn't make him weak at all.
It's not unmanly for Amanda cry.
I've always been an emotional person.
So like if a wrestler has to retire
or someone that I really looked up to
watching the TV, watching them make
their speech, I've shed tears, you know,
to that like, so things
like that, you know,
we were given those tiers for a reason.
How do you feel about it,
your relationship with your mother?
Obviously like I said,
I didn't have one, but people
say I talk like her. Um,
she was a humanitarian basis.
She spoke wise and she was
involved with the community.
That's all she cared about.
So I just try to harm her.
My story with my mother is
very touching. It's sad. Um,
I'm proud of her in some ways,
but I'm also disappointed in other ways.
You know,
she was a single mom and she was
using drugs as we were growing up.
She wasn't there very much, but
I know she loved us, but it just,
she had outside influences from
the men that she was bringing in.
We were evicted out of our house
when I was 19 years old. Um,
I ended up taking care of my 12 year
old brother and then my mom ended up
homeless.
My mom was homeless for 10
years and unfortunately it's
hard to help people that
really don't want the help.
You know,
she went to a Rehab facility and
she got off drugs for a little bit,
but then she relapsed and got
back along and it was very,
very frustrating and there was a period
of time we're writing communicate with
her and right now she's trying to get
her life back in order. I love my mom.
I'm just praying and I'm hoping that
she can stay clean and I just wanted to
know that I do love her
just because our F my own
family dynamic is something I,
I don't generally share with the public.
I know she loves me and you know,
we love, I love her too, but it's
very challenging to communicate.
And um,
and that is what I will say for that
complete this sentence. I wish I
had someone with whom I could share
life. I would say I'm single right
now. So this is something that, um,
I don't know if I'm like really
searching for it right now yet. Uh,
but I think definitely in the future or
would like to be able to share life with
someone.
Yeah,
you'll get it. I believe that sometimes
it comes to you when you least expect it.
And that's what I learned.
The universe handled that
like with mine came last year.
It wasn't exciting nervous,
it's just she just came along.
She was really,
she was so, yeah, you can't look forward.
It's kind of the universe
will do the work.
It's like a mailman when you put
a letter in the mailbox, right.
You don't go keep, you don't go to that
mailbox everyday or to the and say, hey,
did you met with my letter off?
It's the PostNet his job now.
So do it and leave it alone if
it's four years going to happen.
And that's how relationships
are too. Hmm. Yeah. So,
well,
I would say someone who I can grow with
substantially in many aspects of life.
I think the perfect woman that most
people would agree with would be someone
that's supportive,
is motivating you can grow with and that
you can learn from someone with a great
personality and a determination and a
drive and a woman that is also independent
as well and that will support you and
what you want to do and that will always
listen to you and that somebody
that you can confide in. Yeah,
I believe that would
make up a perfect woman.
Okay.
There is no terrific women,
no man,
whatever comes to you and it
agrees with chest spirit. Yes.
Your twin flame, that's perfect because
everybody's not going to understand you.
You guys can be the panda helmets
when you're riding motorcycles.
That's perfection. There's personally
cause you guys invited. Yeah.
Man,
that's a great thing about you as you
can really put things into perspective.
Definitely.
Thank you.
Tell the other two what
you like about them.
Be Very honest this time saying things
that you might not say to someone you've
just met.
What I admire about you
is how honest you are. Um,
you offer amazing perspective
on everything. Um,
you seem very spiritual and comfortable
with who you are as a person and who
have you grown into. And then for
you, your life story is amazing.
What you've been through and how you
overcame the bullying and everything. Um,
I really admire that about you.
Thank you very much. You're welcome.
Yeah,
I will say that about you too.
Cause hurt people usually hurt
people and we didn't take that route.
So that's commendable.
Your whole aura five is peaceful.
You can't keep a piece without chaos.
All of the chaos in your life has
given you peace. That's beautiful man.
I would say one thing I really
admired about you right now,
you're very insightful. Like what
you said earlier about why me. Right?
And that was kind of like,
wow. Yeah, I mean, yeah,
I really admire your vulnerability.
You being able to share those challenging
circumstances in life and it's an
honor to be here, both of you, both
of you guys at kings, you know,
for lunch he'd been through and
like I said, you can lead a war.
You can lead an army. Maybe
you don't think so. The,
all the things that you been prepared
for your whole life prepared you for.
You can't become a shot in master
unless you go through the training.
I think they spiked it
actually. Oh, did they?
That's it.
And so by the end of the afternoon,
David Curtis and Damon,
three men who had never met before,
had drank about three liters
together and became pretty friendly
in the next episode. And unlikely trio
of young folk shed some tears over tea.
Also check out some of her other work.
You might enjoy it until next time.